what a sweet-ass run it's been
forces of darkness and light
universe now
we're seeing a lot of passing the batons
of different characters to the next
iterations Kate bishop you mentioned the
Hawkeye series could the next Avengers
we see be Young Avengers have you guys
thought about like do you know what the
next of interesting looks like yes and
it will be it will be a very different
team than we've seen before that's what
endgame was all about yeah it would be a
very different incarnation of the team
with some people you've already met and
some people you haven't mega this movie
is going to show you what Peter's place is
going to be in this universe moving forward
there's lots of Easter eggs to the
future of what my Spider Man might
become welcome back everyone its Charlie
this is going to be my new video about
Avengers 5 and the other Avengers
related movies like young Avengers that
Kevin Feige and the other Marvel
producers have been talking about in the
past week we're still doing the giveaway
for that giant infinity Saga box set of
all the Marvel films all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave your best theory about Avengers 5
on the video so recently Marvel just
revealed more plans about what's going
on with Avengers 5 in their grand plan
for the next 10 years of Marvel films
building up to their next infinity war
and Avengers endgame level events as
those clips imply and what they've been
setting up through spider-man far from
home that also involves the future of
the spider-man character because not
only is he the metaphorical and literal
face of Marvel Comics they've literally
used his face on every single one of
their comics he's also the connection to
the new Marvel films the next 10 years
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe and all
the stuff that came before because he
has this deep connection to Iron Man and
Iron Man is the last 10 years of Marvel
now you see why it's so important that
Marvel and Sony worked out that new
sharing deal because it would have
crumbled everything that they were
setting up for the next 10 years they
would have had to scramble and come up
with a different plan it would have been
way less cool but breaking down all the
specific stuff from their interview top
5 style so they said number 5 they
referenced a lot of Easter eggs passing
a Bhutan's New Avengers Young Avengers
all the teasers at the end of Avengers
and game for those new people that will
be joining the next version of the
Avengers team that's them just
confirming that some of the original
Avengers will come back the ones that
are still alive during Marvel phase 4 I
know you all have crazy Black Widow
theories about her coming back to life
but Scarlett Johansson
been pretty clear that she is dead in
present day there is another black widow
that's coming along too but her name is
Jelena Bulova she's not one of the new
characters that I'm talking about though
she's more of a Dark Avengers
Thunderbolts type of character but
before I talk about the actual roster of
characters for Avengers 5 the important
thing that Kevin Feige is producing
partner Marvel trend Tron just said is
that Avengers 5 is going to be way way
smaller of a movie in terms of number of
characters than Avengers infinity war
and avengers endgame you all probably
knew that but Marvel just wanted to make
it clear that it took them 10 years to
get to an Avengers movie this big and
it's going to take another 10 years to get
to the next big event so that's why
Marvel phase 4 spending so much time
introducing brand new characters and
there's no big Avengers movie on that
roster of movies for that means for sure
we can say Avengers 5 is not going to be
the secret Wars storyline and because of
all the spider-man far from home post
credits scenes with Nick Fury on the
sword Space Station in the scene of the
scrolls and Talos referencing the Kree
sleeper cells on earth we can say
Avengers 5 will still be a relatively
cosmic story as in the Avengers movies
are moving into outer space
but they still invoke Planet Earth so
it's not like they're going to go to the
other side of the universe and then come
back to Planet Earth after Avengers 5
the whole concept of Avengers is that
you're avenging earth so somebody is
trying to do something to earth it's
just that now they're moving into space
because they're getting into more cosmic
stories so the threats are becoming more
cosmic also meaning cosmic characters
joining the Avengers in a formal way
right now the biggest Marvel comic book
stories that they could do that are set
around planet Earth but are also big
cosmic stories are Secret Invasion they
kind of teased that with the Kree
sleeper cells but it was a Kree twist
instead of the scrolls being the ones
invading it would be the Kree there's
the coming of Galactus of course they're
going to do Galactus at some point but
probably not right away more in
Fantastic Four in a second - there's the
annihilation storyline an eyeless
completely new character that they've
never done before also a really huge
cosmic threat there's a version of Dark
Avengers they could do with either Red
Hulk general Ross instead of Norman
Osborn or go full Norman Osborn Dark
Avengers like the comics then there's
war of Kings and realm of Kings which
are both stories that involve a lot of
other x-men characters and the Inhumans
in a
sounds like they might actually bring
the Inhumans back through the Miss
Marvel Disney Plus series the reason why
I don't mention Secret Wars on that list
is because three based on what the
Marvel producer with Kevin Feige is
saying is that their next 10 year level
event that they're building up to will
be Avengers secret Wars or something
similar to that
they changed the comics so much so don't
count on whatever that winds up being
being exactly like the comic book
storyline and I know a lot of you have
asked whether or not they do the
original secret Wars or the newer secret
Wars
both are really cool but the original
secret Wars is mostly known as the
Beyonder just forcing all the Avengers
and Marvel characters from the 6-1-6
universe including spider-man to test
themselves on a distant rock just do
battle fight each other will sell a lot
of toys no joke Marvel ruled out all
kinds of tie-in toys for this and it was
way before they were doing big movie
tie-ins Marvel super villains and
superheroes figures each sold separately
he Doctor Doom in the doom platoon
Captain America and the champions of
freedom spider-man Wolverine secret Wars
the secrets out
Doctor Doom and spider-man the marvel
secret Wars collection most people
remember that story because it was when
Spiderman got the alien symbiote costume
for the first time the newer Secret Wars
from the last couple of years was a big
multiversal event remix of the original
secret wars same concept you have a
world that everyone's forced to fight on
they called it battle world but the
story was so much deeper and so much
more complex a group of extra
dimensional aliens called the beyonders
start destroying the multiverse one
universe at a time Doctor Strange the
Illuminati dr. doom and the Cabal have
to find a way to stop them from wiping
everything from existence dr. doom
eventually claims all their power for
himself becomes a god and in a
last-ditch attempt to save what parts of
reality he can he stitches together
aspects of different universes into one
amalgam version of earth populated by a
ton of different versions of all the
characters it was a really cool story
but even trying to explain it in a
single paragraph takes a lot if you
didn't read it you're also probably a
little confused right now that's why you
have to wait 10 years to build up to a
story like that because there's so many
concepts that you have to do first they
have to do dr. strange to multiverse of
madness to explain the multiverse you
have to introduce the Fantastic Four in
the x-men characters which won't happen
till really tale in Marvel phase 4
Marvel phase 5 you have to introduce
more cosmic concepts like the beyonders
Galactus Silver Surfer and people that
live in transdimensional space they've
already started to tease that during
ant-man in the wasp and Avengers endgame
with the quantum energy in the quantum
realm there are infinite numbers of
universes in the multiverse but only one
quantum realm connecting them all that's
why they were able to use the quantum
energy to travel through time and space
and travel between different realities
created by the branch timelines like
that's how old Captain America got back
to this original reality because he was
living out his life in an alternate
timeline with that version of Peggy
Carter I know there were a lot of
questions about the path of older
Captain America but the Russos and the
writers both came out after the movie
and explained that he lived in an
alternate timeline then used the quantum
energy to jump back to the original
timeline where we saw them
tesseract Loki is also a good example
that - he created a branch timeline when
he stole the tesseract so if he shows up
during Thor for love and thunder he'll
have to hop between realities most of
Marvel phase 4 Marvel phase 5 will just
be spent going deeper on a lot of those
concepts so that by the time we get to
Secret Wars in another 10 years it'll
all make sense to people that don't read
Marvel Comics - all the Avengers
characters that Kevin Feige said are
coming back include Thor ant-man
spider-man of course and the Hulk maybe
Scarlet Witch envisioned they might have
them ride the bench after Doctor Strange
- and even though they didn't formally
become Avengers during endgame you have
black panther early prediction he
becomes the new de facto team leader
filling in for Iron Man because he's got
all the money in the world to fund the
team and the leadership skills but the
Avengers movies typically only involves
six to eight superheroes at most and
because Avengers 5 is going to be
smaller it'll be a smaller roster and
with Black Panther and Captain Marvel we
already have six characters so some of
those b-list characters will still have
to ride the bench because number one the
New Avengers people we have not met yet
but will meet during Marvel phase four
involve shang-chi he's getting his own
solo movie of course he's going to be on
the next Avengers roster I've already
done a preview video for what that movie
is there's been a couple of teasers it's
going to explain who the real Mandarin is
then there's the Turtles characters that
they're introducing during that movie
Kevin Feige already said the kit
harington's Black Knight character will
be in an Avengers movie so that confirms
he's going to be on the next roster they
typically only introduced two to three
new characters in every Avengers movie
Avengers 6 is probably when we'll start
seeing more of those cosmic x-men and
Fantastic Four characters like Reed
Richards Silver Surfer and more Galactus
stuff but I will do more videos about
Avengers 5 Marvel phase forge they
announced stuff I will be doing episode
videos for the mandalorian and Rick and
Morty season 4 both of those will also
be starting in the next couple of weeks
- so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all the
videos when I post them but everybody
click here for that new boys season 2
teaser trailer and click here to watch
the spider-man producers talk about the
new sinister 6 spider-man movie that
they're working on thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!